[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about whether fans of
Dragon Ball Z who might have grown up
with the show or even gone into anime
because of DBZ should bother watching
Dragon Ball super which is the ongoing
sequel to Dragon Ball Z that premiered
almost 20 years after Dragon Ball Z
finished airing I decided to make this
video because I'm one of the people who
grew up watching Dragon Ball Z back in
the early 2000s when the show finally
made its way to North America and as a
huge DBZ fan I was very skeptical about
Dragon Ball super at first in fact I
didn't watch it for a long time after it
started airing because I was afraid that
the show would somehow ruin my childhood
memories but about a year after it first
started airing I finally decided to
catch up on Dragon Ball super and now
I'm going to tell you whether Dragon
Ball super is worth watching in my
opinion we made a poll on our Twitter
about what type of Dragon Ball content
you want to see us make here on the
channel and this topic of Dragon Ball Z
versus Dragon Ball super one the last
poll so that is why I'm making this
video for you guys if you want to take
part in future polls to help us decide
what type of videos to make next you can
follow us on Twitter and we are also
posting daily on Instagram at anime
uproar for both links are in the
description if you end up enjoying this
video and you want to see more don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell thank you to rift e
beets for the background music he makes
cool remixes of anime soundtracks
including dragon ball music you can
check out his channel link in the
description now the question of whether
a fan of Dragon Ball Z will enjoy Dragon
Ball super is a subjective one if you
watch Dragon Ball Z as a child and liked
it but now that you've gotten older you
only enjoy mature and serious anime
movies TV shows and so on the Dragon
Ball super is probably not for you
Dragon Ball super has it's serious
moments just like Dragon Ball Z did but
overall it is an action anime that
focuses on fighting and advance
sure if you're looking for a deeply
philosophical anime that will make you
think about the meaning of life Dragon
Ball super is not the perfect choice
however Dragon Ball super does offer
four unique things that I think a fan of
John Ball Z will appreciate number one
is world building if you loved the
unique and interesting world of Dragon
Ball Z including the incredible
abilities that the characters possess
and the universe that the story takes
place in then Dragon Ball super does
have a lot to offer in Dragon Ball super
we learned a lot more about the universe
of Dragon Ball and not just one universe
we learned that there are multiple
universes that exist and that the
universe we know from Dragon Ball Z is
just one of those universes in Dragon
Ball super we get to explore and learn
more about not just universe 7 where the
Z fighters come from but also the other
universes and the complex governing
structure that rules over these
universes and this also includes a wide
variety of God's angels and other divine
beings speaking of which in Dragon Ball
super we meet a huge number of new and
interesting characters from the
different universes and beyond
and this really adds to the complexity
and nuance of the world of Dragon Ball
and Dragon Ball super it's not just the
case of the same heroes fighting a new
villain in each art and then moving on
instead we meet a whole bunch of new and
unique characters some good some evil
and some who are in between those two
extremes if you liked the world of
Dragon Ball Z and you're interested in
seeing new planets new characters of
different species and races new divine
beings new and unique abilities and
powers then you should strongly consider
watching Dragon Ball super whether or
not you like the world of Dragon Ball Z
as a fan of the series you definitely
like the characters that we meet along
the way at least some of them anyway if
you've been wondering what happens to
Goku Gohan Vegeta and Bulma Crillon and
Android 18 and everybody else after the
Kid Buu saga Dragon Ball super reveals
this in great detail you get to see how
the relationships between the characters
develop how they start and grow
their families what they do with their
lives how they continue to interact with
each other and so on just to give you
one example I personally really enjoyed
seeing how Vegeta and go Han have
developed into family man who care
deeply for their wives and children and
I love seeing these characters that I've
known since childhood grow evolve and
develop new relationships with each
other there is of course a lot of humor
involved here like in the relationship
between Paul mine Vegeta for example and
I really enjoyed that comedic element as
well when I was first watching Dragon
Ball Z as a kid my favorite character in
the whole show was Future Trunks I loved
how after the epic frieza saga on Namek
where goku struggled for so long to
defeat Frieza Future Trunks just swoops
in and annihilates Frieza and his father
in mere seconds I also loved how Future
Trunks came from a very dark timeline
where he developed into a much different
person than he would have if he had
lived in the present timeline and of
course I appreciated Future Trunks his
sense of fashion including his badass
jacket and sword probably the biggest
reason why I decided to finally give
Dragon Ball super a chance was when I
heard that Future Trunks comes back in
the series and that we get to learn more
about the future timeline and I have to
say I loved learning more about trunks
and seeing the development of his
relationship with characters in the
present timeline especially his
relationship with Vegeta and go Han this
is one of the highlights of Dragon Ball
super for me and if you are one of the
people who loved the main characters in
Dragon Ball Z and you are curious to see
what happens to them next and how their
relationships developed Dragon Ball
super is definitely worth your time in
my opinion number three is pacing and
battle strategy if you're a fan of
Dragon Ball you've got to be a fan of
action and epic battles between
incredibly strong opponents and Dragon
Ball super definitely delivers on this
aspect of the franchise we meet new
insanely powerful characters and this
forces our heroes to get stronger in
order to defeat them and in this sense
there are many similarities to Dragon
Ball Z however there are a few
interesting developments that I see
enjoy
of all super for one the pacing is not
nearly as slow as the original
Dragonball Z in which a single fight
could take nearly 20 episodes and this
was especially hard to deal with when
you were watching the episodes weekly on
TV
in 2009 Dragon Ball Z Kai was released
and it cut out a lot of the slow pacing
and a filler and I think Dragon Ball
super also does a pretty good job of
keeping a fast pace and limiting the
filler to a reasonable extent there is
definitely some filler but I didn't find
it to be as bad as something like the
garlic jr. saga in Dragon Ball Z and
most fights even the epic ones last two
or three episodes not 10 or 20 now some
may disagree with me on this and that's
totally cool but in my opinion Dragon
Ball super at certain times has a bigger
focus on battle strategy then Dragon
Ball Z especially once the big
tournament of power arc gets going
rather than just introducing new more
powerful villains which in turn inspires
everyone to obtain a higher power level
in order to defeat them with pure force
dragon ball super introduces the concept
of a tournament in which multiple teams
of ten fighters must work together to
defeat the other teams and survive this
concept forces us to think about the
importance of teamwork of strategy and
of unique techniques and abilities that
can allow fighters to get the better of
an opponent who is much stronger than
them in terms of physical power alone
once the tournament of power starts it
is also difficult to tell who is the
hero and who is the villain or better
yet maybe there is no villain at all and
that is something that I appreciate life
is often complicated and sometimes there
is no clear-cut good guys and bad guys
just people trying their best to survive
and the tournament of power arc does a
great job of bringing this to life if
that sounds like something that you
might enjoy then Dragon Ball super and
the universe survival saga in particular
is definitely worth watching and number
four is more strong female characters in
Dragon Ball Z we had some notable female
characters including Bulma and chichi of
course and later on in the series
Android 18 Vidal and so on however
Dragon Ball Z
still clearly dominated by male
characters whereas in Dragon Ball super
we meet a lot more badass female
characters including female sands more
strong female fighters from other
universes and powerful female deities
and divine beings I personally enjoyed
seeing all of these new female
characters entered the mix especially
vados who is probably my number one
waifu pick in Dragon Ball with Android
18 a close second let me know who your
favorite female characters are in the
Dragon Ball franchise and in general
tell me how you think Dragon Ball super
stacks up against Dragon Ball Z if
you've already seen Super are you glad
that you gave it a chance and would you
recommend it to your friends give me
your thoughts down in the comments
personally I definitely think that
Dragon Ball super is worth your time if
you enjoyed Dragon Ball or Dragon Ball Z
of course the show isn't perfect but
neither was the original Dragon Ball or
Dragon Ball Z so I definitely think the
show is worth watching and worth your
time but at the end of the day everyone
will make that decision for themselves
and we all have different tastes and
opinions and that's totally cool if you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
dragon ball content in the future be
sure to leave a like to let me know if
you are new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell follow us on Twitter and Instagram
for daily updates at anime uproar and
until next time SIA space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]